[Music]
thank you
chapter 14 of Philip K Dix the man in
the High Castle picks up with one of the
main characters nobusuke tagomi thinking
to himself there is no answer no
understanding even in the Oracle yet I
must go on living day to day anyhow and
what is this about well he is
experiencing a major crisis there was an
attack on the Nippon Times building
where he and uh you know Rudolph Wegner
the Opera operative and the general
we're meeting to discuss this horrific
Nazi plot to attack the Japanese home
islands with nuclear weapons and then
mop up the resistance afterwards and the
SD attacked them and uh tagomi found
himself using a antique pistol that he
had bought lot and practiced with to
kill two of the SD Commandos in order to
save Wagner and this threw him into a
crisis in which he's trying to use the
Oracle the ejing the book of changes to
reintegrate himself but not having much
success and so everything seems as he
says hopeless he says I will go and find
the small live unseen at any rate until
some later time when and it just sort of
goes off of there
so he says goodbye to his wife and he
doesn't go to the Nippon Times building
and he thinks to himself well you know
what about a day of relaxation
and then he thinks trees and Zoo are not
personal I must clutch at human life
and he goes to sell eventually his his
pistol but before that we get these
Reflections going on perhaps I can never
go back to the nip on Times building
with its stink of death my career over
but just as well a replacement can be
found by the Board of Trade Mission
activities but to go me still walks
exists recalling every detail so nothing
is accomplished and he goes on and says
hopeless wherever one looks and there's
this possibility
that the Oracle has actually withdrawn
from the world of man in sorrow the
sages embodied in the Oracle leaving and
he says to himself we have entered a
moment when we are alone we cannot get
assistance as before
well Mr tagomi thought perhaps that too
is good or can be made good one must
still try to find the way so what he's
looking for is some sort of guidance to
the path that he ought to take out of
the different possibilities ahead of him
so he then goes to Robert childen's shop
to try to sell the revolver now why is
he going to do that because he thinks
that well if I can get rid of this then
maybe I can begin my life again he's
saying is all of my instinct perverted
from the memory of what I did all
collecting damage not merely the
attitude towards this one item Mainstay
of my life area alas where I dwell with
such relish and so he thinks maybe I
could manage my anxious proclivities by
a ruse trade the gun in on more
historicity sanctioned item This Gun For
Me has too much subjective history all
of the wrong kind but that ends with me
no one else can experience it from a gun
within my psyche only and he thinks I'll
free myself of the cloud of the past now
Mr children not because of all the
things that have happened to Togo me but
in part because of the questionable
provenance and historicity of these
Firearms won't take it back but he
doesn't go into any great detail and
then
He suggests to Togo me I have something
else that you would be interested in
and uh he tells them these are American
made but these are not the old sir these
are the new this is the new life of my
country sir the beginning in the form of
tiny and perishable seeds of beauty and
tagomi looks at them and he says to
himself yes there's something new which
animates these he decided the law of Dao
is borne out here when Yin lies
everywhere Yin being the darker the
receding right uh the first stirring of
light is suddenly alive in the darkest
steps we are all familiar we've seen it
happen before as I see it happen now
here and yet for me they are just scraps
they cannot I cannot become wrapped as
Mr Children Here unfortunately for both
of us so uh children says sir it does
not occur all at once and what is the
the uh the thing the new view in your
heart and to go me says you're converted
and he actually says your certitude
isn't questionable taste your
Anglo-Saxon fanaticism does not appeal
to me and and he leaves
and then he thinks to himself
you know maybe I should give this a try
something is being offered to me here
what if I had bought one of those odd
indistinct items kept it re-examined
contemplated would I have subsequently
through it found my way back I doubt it
those are for him not me and then he has
a turning point where he says to himself
yet if he if even if one person finds
his way that means there is a way even
if I personally fail to reach it and so
he tells children I'll buy one of these
little blob like squiggle-like pieces of
jewelry and he leaves the shop and then
he goes to a park and he takes the
jewelry out for inspection and Solitude
here in this little grass and path Park
of old men he held the swiggle of silver
reflection of the midday sun he gazed
down on it oh as the brahmins say shrunk
spot in which all is captured and then
he says what's going to happen here and
he he says to himself
forgive me he thought into the direction
of the squiggle there's pressure on us
always to rise and act and he begins to
put it away and then he thinks you know
I should act like a child in in
innocence and he does so he tells the
the thing in satovolta right in in a low
voice the sales warranty promised much
he's thinks to himself maybe I should
wake it up and he actually does a bunch
of different things tried everything he
realized pleaded contemplated threatened
philosophized at length so he's treating
it as a human treats an artifact
and then he does uh go to a kind of uh
it's both childlike but he also says I
must be scientific systematically in
classic Aristotelian laboratory manner
he holds the silver triangle to his ear
there's no sound and he says what other
sense might apprehend mystery
so he smells it and there's nothing but
a faint metallic odor taste he puts it
in his mouth no meaning only bitter hard
cold thing he held it again in his palm
back at last to seeing highest ranking
of the senses and he's looking over it
over again and now he starts to think
right uh metal is from the earth he
thought as he scrutinized from below
from that realm which is the lowest the
most dense Yin world and its most
Melancholy aspect the world of corpses
Decay and collapse of feces all that has
died slipping and disintegrating back
down layer by layer the Demonic world of
the immutable the time that was so
that's one side one aspect of it
and yet he goes on in the sunlight the
silver triangle glittered it reflected
light fire Mr tagomi thought not dank or
dark objectives at all not heavy wearing
but pulsing with life the high realm
aspect of Yang empyrion ethereal as
befits a work of art and he thinks
that's what the artist has done here
brought the dead to life the past has
yielded to the Future what are you he
asked the silver squiggle dark dead Yin
or brilliant living young
body of Yin soul of young metal and fire
unified the outer and inner
microcosmos in my palm and now he's
paying more and more attention into it
he's sort of going through it and he's
there's this reference to the Bartle
total afterlife existence he says I
don't have to wait for death the
decomposition of my animus my my mind my
soul as it wanders in search of a new
womb all the terrifying and beneficent
deities we will bypass them in the Smoky
lights as well and the couples and
coitus everything except this light I am
ready to face with Terror and he says I
feel the hot Winds of karma driving me I
won't shrink from the clear white light
what is this well this is a way out of
the cycle of birth and death but he's
not dying he's experiencing this in his
his life right
so suddenly he's drawn back to the
present how there's a tall blue suited
policeman smiling and says I was just
watching you work that puzzle to go home
he says it's not a puzzle and he says oh
you know my kids have a whole bunch of
those sorts of things and tagomi thinks
this stupid yank this white Barbarian
Neanderthal this sub-human supposing I
worked a child's Purell toy right and
then he thinks to himself oh that's it's
really racist that's below me I
shouldn't be thinking those sorts of
things and what does he find the city he
inhabited has changed there are no
pedicabs there's
no way of getting around in the way that
he's used to and then he sees
um something else
he stopped gaped at hideous misshapen
thing on Skyline like a nightmare of
roller coaster suspended blotting out
the view in enormous construction of
metal and cement in the air and he'd
asked somebody what is that and the man
grinned the awful Isn't it that's the
Embarcadero freeway a lot of people
think that it stinks up the view and
tagumi says I never saw it before and
the man said well you're lucky and
tagomi is thinking this is a mad dream I
must wake up where are the pedicabs he
doesn't find any instead only cars and
buses all unfamiliar in shape and so he
goes into a restaurant a dingy Lunch
Counter only whites within supping right
and these are going to be undeferential
why it's all the stools are taken by
them he exclaims several whites looked
up but none departed their places none
yielded their stools to him they merely
remained supping I insist Mr tagumi said
loudly to the first White he shouted the
man's ear the man put down his coffee
mug and said watch it Tojo
Mr tagomi looked to the other whites
I'll watch with hostile expressions and
then tagomi thinks aha this is Bartle uh
total existence hot winds blowing me who
knows where this is a vision
but of what and he says you know the
Book of the Dead helps to prepare us for
this where am I and he realizes the
silver triangle disoriented me I broke
from my Moorings and hence stand on
nothing the lesson to me is forever one
seeks to contravene one's perception so
you can wander utterly lost without
signposts or guide and he he says to
himself that he's out of his world his
space his time and we could also say
that the world there includes the
culture the dominance hierarchy all of
the history that's in there and he
thinks to himself I've got to get back
to my own place uh and he feels in his
pockets for the silver triangle and he
realizes oh crap I left that and the
briefcase that's got my gun in it in the
park I better go and get them so he he
does that and then he's trying to to
refocus
concentration and thereby restore his
ego Center and he gets it and begins
focusing on it and he focuses uh and
says scrutinize it forcefully and count
at 10 utter startling noise ervaca for
instance which is you know German for
get wake up and so he actually ends up
doing that and gets up and he's back in
his own world
diffusion subsided in all probability
and he says now one appreciates Saint
Paul's incisive word choice seen through
glass Darkly is not a metaphor but
astute reference to Optical Distortion
we really do see a stigma to
estigmatically in fundamental sense our
space and our time our creations of our
own psyche and when these momentarily
falter it's like an acute disturbance of
the middle ear we lose our balance and
so he says I'm going to go and check to
see if that awful freeway is there and
then he calls some two little Chinese
boys and says hey I'll give you a dime
go check to see if there's any pedicabs
over there they come back and that's how
he realizes he is now back in his own
world and a reintegration has occurred
for him through this
he thinks to himself back to office and
job something that was precluded by the
crisis that he was in he rose to his
feet gripping the handle of his
briefcase duty calls customary day once
again he gets in a pedicab and he says
take me to the Nippon Times building and
that's where he's going to have the
encounter with uh the reichs council and
and also experience some some medical
conditions as well but that's outside of
the scope of this particular important
moment which shows us that the world of
the narrative isn't the only possible
world that there is one in which the
axis didn't win World War World War II
perhaps multiple worlds in which that
didn't occur because we have the story
of the grasshopper lies heavily as well
so this is is the resolution
of an important crisis where to go me
shifts whether he's actually going into
another dimension or another parallel
world or whether this is as he's saying
you know a lack of concentration and
then being drawn into something else
which isn't quite as real a kind of
hallucination so that's left unresolved
here in this part of Dick's the man in
the High Castle